the numbers behind this story continue
to be very sobering indeed the number of
deaths reported today was one of the
biggest daily totals of any European
country so far now this chart shows the
total number of reported death and how
they've been rising today as you can see
the total is now just over 7,000 but in
order to chart our progress in
controlling this virus we need to
understand the speed at which these
numbers are rising so have a look at
this in early March the number of deaths
was doubling roughly every two days it
then started to slow and as you can see
there now it's doubling roughly every
four days this helps to explain why this
is the number of deaths reported each
day today's 938 is the biggest total yet
but while those bars are getting bigger
they have started to level off ever so
slightly in recent days now that
leveling is even clearer if we show it
to you in a chart that tracks trends so
look at this this is exactly the same
data just displayed in what we call a
logarithmic chart the bars showed the
deaths and the line shows the expected
growth according to recent trends now
you see there's a little space there
between the line and the bars
it's that space which offers a small
glimmer of hope emits what's still a
very dark picture because it shows that
the reported deaths have ever so
slightly under shot expectations but the
pace of growth isn't the same in all
parts of the UK our analysis shows that
while London's still accounts for the
most deaths the numbers there are now
increasing at a slower pace than
elsewhere this shows the percentage
increase in death by nation and by
English region since last Friday
as you can see London is actually right
down there at the bottom while Scotland
the Northeast and Yorkshire and the
Northwest all grew by well over a
hundred percent the same shifting
balance is clear when you look at the
number of people in hospital beds this
chart was presented at today's press
conference and while the total number in
the UK rose by 5 percent in the last 24
hours
it was up 16% in the East of England you
see that labeled G there it raises
questions
whether the lockdown could be lifted at
different times in different regions but
in reality we're probably some weeks
away from any restrictions coming to an
end